[Music]
the surgeon is real the tools are real
the surgery is real
the patient is artificial I took what I
learned from special effects and now I
apply it to helping the kids here at the
hospital my name is Gregory loan and I'm
a senior simulation engineer at Boston
Children's Hospital I make artificial
patients to allow real doctors to
practice procedures to improve health
outcomes for kids I do not think that I
could do this work without having had
the experiences that I had in special
effects well I was working in special
effects I got the opportunity to build
dinosaurs for the Jurassic Park theme
parks and magical creatures for Harry
Potter and all kinds of wonderful things
to bring that experience to life for
people
I ultimately left special effects to go
focus in on robotics which is my other
passion in life the best part is now I
combine special effects robotics and
engineering and medicine into package
that helps people
I make simulation models some of them
are really low-tech
like an arm that you can inject or
practice line placement all the way up
to and including gunshot wound patients
and advanced surgical techniques like
cleft lip repair at the end of the day I
know that my contribution helps kids
because the creations that we make here
go towards saving children's lives
[Music]